the cast of maybe I do reunite for a
screening in New York City and Emma
Roberts fills the tea on having her
aunt's rom-com partner now play her
father I saw
um Runaway Bride and obviously Pretty
Woman and sounds to have him be playing
my dad now it feels like it's like full
circle in the Roberts family so what
Drew Richard to the role Susan and I it
was built in we had a relationship Diane
I worked with 40 years ago bill I'd
always admired you know sort of four of
us really just kind of had a built-in
respect but I think also a ability to do
this kind of thing the symbol of our
love this ring means commitment where
the hell's a ring yeah
[Music]
over in La the cast of you people hit
the black carpet for the premiere and
Julia Louis Dreyfus poke some fun at her
character Shelley I've lived in Los
Angeles a long time and and raised my
kids here so I'm very familiar with
Shelley's can you honestly say that your
family is excited to have my black
Adventure
oh my gosh you are so beautiful I think
the police okay are
up towards black people while director
Kenya Barrett shares what the movie
means to him a love letter Love Letter
to La a love letter with a culture and a
love letter to love what's up with white
girls
am I white guys
well I'm not I'm white guys for sure
what's the difference between me and you